- You had a home birth for
your second baby, right?
- For Banks, yeah and for Mae.
- So for your second and third?
- Yes.
- Was that, I mean, was that like a
cause you had your first
one in the hospital.
- Yup.
- And you had a fine experience probably,
but what was the reason why'd
you wanna do home birth?
cause it kind of terrifies
me cause I had complications.
So you never know when you're
gonna have complications.
- Yeah, yeah, Well, you know what?
I think that I had a really
easy first birth with Luca
in the hospital, so I was
kind of like, all right
I know my body can do this.
I didn't have any issues.
- Great body, okay, yeah.
(audience laughter)
- My body was not that body.
- You know what?
Some people like aren't,
birthers like that.
- Yeah, my sister's like you.
- My mom was like you.
So it's weird.
I was very like, much
more comfortable doing it
in the hospital for the first time.
And then I watched Ricky Lake's business
of being born and I was like,
I think I could do this.
I think I can.
- Wait. I missed that.
So wait, it was just
like a home birth movie?
- It's a home birth documentary.
- Oh, I missed that.
- You know what was really cool
about the home birth Kelly?
It's like, you know,
you're bringing a baby
into the world,
that's some of the hardest
work anybody can do.
- Amen.
- And they don't let you have
like water in the hospital
or food or snacks.
And you're about to like work the hardest
you've ever worked to
like push a baby out.
- So at home you get all?
- Oh, I had sugar fish in bed.
I had a glass of rose.
- You had sushi?
- I had sushi in my bed
with my baby and a glass
of rose that I actually was
like clawing at the bit to have.
And then I took a sip
afterwards and I was like
it's not doing it for me.
- Yeah.
- But the day after I had some.
- That's amazing I'm so glad.
That's such a cool experience too
for like your kids when they grow up
it's like you are born at home.
That's so special.
- You know what?
It's kind of the most
hippy dippy thing about me.
Like to have like my kids
around while I'm birthing.
At first I thought it was
really weird, but it was really
beautiful to like bring
another family member
in with everyone else.
- I don't think it's very hippie dippie,
but I think it's self-sustaining, it's
like you can do everything at your home.
I think that's awesome.
- You know what?
One of my favorite memories
was like Luca decided to
sing Mae happy birthday.
And I was like, I've never
heard of anyone singing
happy birthday on a like
entering date, but he was like
we should sing a happy birthday.
- I think that's so precious.